okay does everyone know how to use these
that easier than me screaming well
welcome to Ways and Means so when you
use these just make sure you turn it off
when you're done so that any of your
background noise just doesn't get sent
around
well welcome we have a big year ahead of
us uh as you know Ways and Means is tax
tasks with many things including looking
at bills that are sent our way but also
importantly looking at Revenue estimates
and coming up with a proposal for our
house budget writers
so today I thought we'd just get
organized get to know each other a
little bit we will start by doing some
introductions we have some staff here
who will introduce themselves and tell
us a little bit about what they do then
I'd like to go around the room with all
of our members here if you could
introduce yourselves tell us a little
bit about your background maybe your
experience in the house your experience
outside of the house so we know what
kind of perspective you have coming into
here and uh and then we'll start to go
in more detail about you know processes
and procedures of the committee and get
all in sync on that and make a plan for
the next few weeks and then we will
break for lunch around 11 30. I have
lunch coming in assortment of sandwiches
and drinks and so forth so hopefully you
can stay we have permission to do that
that's a little unusual to have food in
committee rooms but we have permission
to do that on this special day so and my
hope is that during that time you will
get to know each other more personally
and you know the best best part of
serving in the house I know we have a
lot of freshmen in the room is the
committee work this is where we do the
Deep dive on policy this is where you
become the experts on these policies and
this is where you'll make the best
friends you'll have right here in this
room so um we'll have that lunch period
the Republicans will caucus separately
from 12 30 to 1 15 and that will be
upstairs in lob 300a it's a separate
room for that purpose and then we'll
reconvene at 1 30 and we'll have the CPA
Society of New Hampshire and they will
give us a broad overview of New
Hampshire business tax policy and I will
tell you I just read today there's an
organization that you will come to know
called the tax foundation and they give
us Good Records on how is New Hampshire
tax policy compared to other states and
all different types and we were ranked
seventh in this in the country for
positive corporate business tax climate
and we just were raised to number six
yay so congratulations that's all of
your hard work so thank you for all of
that so uh if I could uh Chris would you
like to just say hello and introduce
yourself and then Jennifer
thanks
good morning crochet I'm from the
legislative budget Assistance office and
I'll be assisting the committee when you
do Revenue estimates I just wanted to
say a quick hello today especially for
the new members I left the flyer a
little pamphlet on your desk talks about
what our office does rifle and a
business card so if you have any
question feel free to email or give me a
call I'll be back I'm just making a
quick one today because I got stuff to
do back at the office in terms of
getting fiscal notes on bills they can
get introduced so that you can do your
committee work
but if there's any quick questions
before I take off I feel happy to try to
address it
thank you we thank you for everything
you do so Chris is going to be very
helpful to us this entire year we will
see a lot of him so
thank you
Jennifer do you want to come up and say
hi
asked you guys all this week
I should all
um but I'm Jennifer for I'm your
um I also work with the education
legislative Administration and Judiciary
committees
um so
if I'm not here I'm probably down the
hall somewhere or upstairs
our office is on the fourth floor I can
help
with background research
um
comparative research to what's going on
in others
um anything that I can do to help you
so I'll be here talk to me looking
forward to this session
thank you
thank you Jennifer and later on I'll
talk to you a little bit more about the
types of things Jennifer can help us
with in terms of research for the
committee she will be very very helpful
as we compare bills from year to year
revenues Etc thank you
want to come up Karen thank you
no it is right
um I just have a few things to go over
there is no attendant sheets there
that's why I passed out all the mileage
she
um she know that we have that
um the there's one copy of the bill that
you'll get um as soon as we get them
printed they're still coming from The
Print Shop so as soon as we get them I
will get you copies
that is the only copy that you'll get
though for we won't have any for
executive session
that there are extras but those are
public
um the drawers are our made up and
they're all empty at the moment so if
there's any problems with any of the
drawers if you could let me know and I
could switch them around
um the name plates this year we're going
to try to use
plates for substitute
so if you could please give me back
those
um paper
name plates when you use them if you're
a substitute on another committee bring
them back to me so we'll always have
that for the
and as soon as we get the blocks you'll
all have wooden blocks so about it thank
you
I can chase mine down from Science and
Tech I have yours oh okay yep I'll bring
it in thank you
thank you
thank you Karen
okay
um I think this would be a good time to
just go around the room and introduce
yourself to the fellow committee members
tell us a little bit about yourself uh
representative rochement would you like
to start thank you
good morning my name is Dave roeschford
I'm from Littleton
um
so my background really is I'm from New
Hampshire been raised here born here
born north of the notches and that's
where I've been uh living under that
rock my whole life
um I'm a pharmacist by profession and my
family has owned pharmacies in the North
Country since the 70s and I actually had
a far Specialty Pharmacy that I started
and ran just until about a year ago in
Littleton where I had um
and given sent with the opportunity to
sell my business so uh relatively newly
uh
change of life if you will uh sold my
business in February and the company
that I'm working for now uh when I
presented to them this idea of me
running for the legislature they said
great go ahead do it as long as you get
your work done
plus that so
um
and I saw I got put on ways and means
I'm like there's no way I'm going to be
able to get my work done and then do
this but but no I'm actually looking
very very much looking forward to Ways
and Means uh you know as I
contemplated which committees to request
Ways and Means was definitely a choice
of mine primarily because
um I didn't think I'd get on it but uh
you know even though I'm a pharmacist by
profession uh and that's where my my
last 25 years has been I'm also a
business owner and have been a business
owner and have developed a business and
I'm sure grown a business I'm sure so
much as I claim to be a pharmacist it's
business part of things that gets me
going so uh I'm excited to be here
excited to participate
um
can't wait to everybody
thank you
representative fellows
thank you madam chair
um Sally fellows I'm a New Hampshire
native I was born in Keene and grew up
mostly in Plymouth and now I live in
holderness my du my district is Plymouth
holderness Ashland
um I worked at the Department of
Education for 30 years in my expertise
is school funding and school Finance
and I've had a little bit of exposure to
the state budget from that work at the
Department of Education
so this is my third term the first two
years were at Edna and I'm happy to be
here because I love data and I love
spridge
you came to the right place
representative Schomburg thank you madam
chair I am representative Tom Schamberg
I'm from Merrimack County six the towns
of uh Wilmot and Sutton which is near
New London uh we're off Interstate 89
exits uh 10 and 11. uh this is my fourth
term serving on New Hampshire house
committee on ways and means I'm a
retired teacher of 30 years I have a JD
I'm a former mayor in Ohio with 14 and a
half years of a service I am presently a
third term Board of selectman in Wilmot
and a
six-term
uh
Municipal budget committee for the
school district
my mayor's position on the selectman's
position has given me uh a lot of budget
developing background
I am like all of you an advocate for
good fair tax policies for all New
Hampshire taxpayers uh I believe
treating all the same without advocating
for any bias treatment
during this term I'm hoping that we all
can review with an open mind possible
Avenues
of local property of reducing local
property taxes especially for public
education
thank you
thank you representative ulery
that's my brother
all right so that's an inside joke my
brother uh lives over in
Northwood area he says he pronounces the
name
jewelry and I pronounce it ulery
no no no it's
it's an inside joke
Phantom chair uh my name is Jordan ulery
I represent the town of Hudson right now
I have formerly represented Hudson
Litchfield in Pelham Hudson and Pelham
whatever
more than one term up here so you get uh
at least two
um redistricting
right term of office
in my real life
worked as uh I was one of the first
paramedics in the state one of the first
paramedics in the nation one of the
first registered EMTs in the nation
uh I've done a lot of uh Public Health
Service on the emergency side and then I
did fraud investigations a private
investigator for several um significant
Insurance Company
um mostly looking for
people who didn't exactly want to play
by the rule
that was a lot of fun if you like
watching asphalt grow
about time watching
yeah served on Ways and Means helped
develop several budgets up here uh had
some input
us and minus I'm also co-chair for Alec
for the State of New Hampshire
uh I'm on their tax and policy test
Court
it's a great deal
various other states
someday tax policy in New Hampshire
that's that of Utah so
number one so
Utah has
their governor's office has a
traditional governor's office has gold
foil wallpaper I don't think we're going
to get that far
but
because we don't have well we do have
gold mines it's not big ones
uh
that's basically where I am and if you
have any questions
I've already seen emails that I've sent
out I follow uh tax Foundation
there'll be some stuff coming out from
Alex
because it's
oh
there are a few good things in there and
I think
trend is next
welcome representative Southworth
when you get settled
would you mind introducing yourself to
the members
I'm so organized I forgot my wallet and
turned around and went
um oh I'm Tom Southworth I represent uh
the city of Dover
it's a new District district 11. as
Dover award for B and Madbury
my background is in public education
I work 43 years reading teacher mainly
as a school counselor and I ended as an
administrator
I worked on many budgets I was a
negotiator so I was used to salaries
language benefits that kind of stuff
um
locally for Stratford County I'm on the
executive committee and I chair the
revenue committee and then also I'm
selectman for my award
um I like math so in a way this
committee appealed to me so I hadn't
done things with billions much before
um
and you know I mean my perception is
we've worked well together as I said to
you math is math so often regardless of
the intentions of a bill the math needs
to work for all of us so it's not
unusual for us to be in agreement
thank you so much representative Ames
foreign
eating in a way that
enables us all to start knowing one of
them
um so I've been here for uh this is my
11th year
and um
have uh I think learned a lot during
I'm
going back I started out I went to law
school
between eight and on into uh to serve in
the uh Peace Corps for four years with
my wife in Philippine
then um came back and worked in the city
of Boston
uh for the city of Boston Auto cities
program for four years
in the uh areas of roxburgh or chest
then um
moved on from there to state government
where I was a general counsel a part of
the leadership team
executive office of educational affairs
for four years and then after that moved
over to the State Department of Mental
Health which at that time at
jurisdiction
with mental illness as well as mental
reading
um
a huge agency it was still running the
big old State Institution
eight schools they were called schools
for the and
and huge State Hospital
all of that was closing down
phasing out into a more community-based
systems I have to oversee that I was a
general counsel but I
part of the management
I had at one time 40 lawyers working for
me
next to the
so after that
um I went into practice on my own
and uh ran on my own little small
business uh
um
and mostly worked uh
what was familiar and that was working
with
we're dealing with mental illness or
disabilities
needed help in getting services
so that's what I did for a while
some of some tax work as well
and um and I came to New Hampshire
for long I got into the
oh um I I am
always been interested in tax policy
this is the place to get get into it and
uh
depth and I enjoy that part here
as
I'm sad
um
we often find a way to come in place in
this committee uh because the numbers
work
out of it is just
being right on the detail
I hope and
you need to do that we will diverge
um
some parts of it and
Divergence the obvious
you're upset
representative almond
hi uh Susan Almy I've been on this
committee for
uh buddy
this is my 27th year
and it was an accident
and
I
um went to from graduate school school
and well while in graduate school I
started 25 years of work overseas in
agricultural development and uh and
research
and
um
in my last posting managed to on
become allergic to third world city air
and couldn't do that anymore came home
was sitting in a chair contemplating at
the age of 49 become reading novels the
rest of my life and walked into a
democratic office and got converted to
be a place filler on the on the ballot
and and I'm the only one in our group
that won
but
um I I had thought
in doing that that if I happened to win
it would be an interesting place and I
actually sent a letter around to all of
The Independents and Democrats in
Lebanon which there were very few
Democrats at the time and I said
um I think that working with small
farmers and high-level researchers and
high-level government officials
government officials and the rest of it
and doing a lot of surveys
like that is and doing budgets it's done
a lot of uh
is going to translate to the legislature
and to my surprise it did
and uh I'm still here
so
on I've been chair four times two of
those were during the Great Recession
we don't know if we're facing another of
those or we're just going to face a blip
uh coming but I think it's going to be
extraordinarily difficult for us to deal
with the revenue estimates this term
I had always regarded it being a
somewhat of a looking into a crystal
ball but this time the crystal ball is
broken as far as I
so we really have to all of us bring
the
life experiences and skills that we
bring to this committee bring it to bear
on what can we do to make it more likely
that we'll come out with a real
a revenue estimate or the budgeters to
use guide them on that is going to
actually materialize in some way
thank you representative jinnegan
I come from I'm I'll be serving this
year as your Vice chairman
um my background started off as an
engineering background I have a
bachelor's chemistry Masters
science
spent about 25 years in the computer
software slash engineering space
starting as a programmer in the early
days and
that crew as a senior director of
about 50.
after that I made a complete career
change
um
obviously a state wrapped this firm
um I also
got to get a real estate broker's
license
properties so I managed the income
property
they brokerage
I also always do tax returns which
sometimes can get a little complex so
um but I enjoy doing it and Us action
this committee out of tax
policy
so my background spans from airing
tax taxes
that will
again Lori Sanborn I am a fourth
generation New Hampshire native I
represent Bedford I have been here 12
years which is really hard to believe I
served on Ways and Means for three terms
I have served under representative
chairman Almy as well as chairman uh
major and chairman stepanak I've also
served on Commerce and finance and rules
um
we lost some some strength in this
committee but we we kept some but we
lost we have we have a lot of new people
here I was asked to serve as your chair
because uh we really we need to develop
a team here we need to develop a lot of
knowledge here and we're going to take
the time to do that so I'm very
committed to doing that for all of you
so if we're going to do the best we can
to provide all the information you need
if I miss something please let me know
if you need a lot more information on a
particular topic please let me know
you won't need to memorize anything just
so you know it we were trying to get to
Great Revenue estimates
I can tell you though I am passionate
about tax policy and this is my favorite
committee I am a small business owner
myself I started my career as a banker
for many years and then I went to the
insurance industry and now I help my
husband operate his business one of
which is a restaurant one of which is a
small charitable gaming facility and I
do some real estate development myself
so I'm very excited to make sure we do a
good job for New Hampshire tax policy
and of course get those Revenue
predictions as accurate as we can
knowing that we have some some things
working against us this year but we're
going to do the best we can and I am
here to serve all of you so I look
forward to getting you getting to know
all of you better
representative Platt
thank you madam chairman
this is my third term in the legislature
I first served the first two in science
technology and energy so I speak geek
very well and I tried I'll promise not
to do that here
um I am from glass down I can't say I'm
a New Hampshire native I came from
Massachusetts I moved up here when I was
nine years old and reminded of a
newcomer flatlander not native uh anyway
uh my life is in the electric utilities
industry I've got a masters in power
engineering and an MBA summa laude
and I I first I'll pick through
everything not through everything but
the important of this committee I
started out in rates and did rate design
cost of service and wrote a model to do
that and uh that that part laid me into
director Financial Planning and uh to
direct a strategic planning assistant of
the president unemployed for Public
Service New Hampshire and I wrote the
financial model at Finance Seabrook
uh after that I Allied signal that was
all over Asia developing markets using
discounted cash flow analysis so I did
that in the native currency uh
everywhere except turkey there weren't
enough zeros on the calculator for that
uh the Lira and
life life is a lot of Civic activity uh
several other my last 10 years was the
mass attorney general in the office of
ratepayer advocacy and I represented her
at
the Northeast power coordinating Council
Newark the North America reliability
Council all of the Nepal committees you
can think of uh and then ended my career
and retired I've been active civically
my whole life through JC's and lions my
past Council chair of lions I'm
treasurer of Alliance Satan hearing
foundation with a little over a million
dollar Corpus I'm treasurer of my local
co-op where I live a Medfield
cooperative
a 301 homes 500 Souls was until November
I chose not to run again so that's a
nutshell I've got a lot of financial
planning and financial experience to
bring to this but it's the new committee
to me and I look forward to serving
representative is it Malloy Malloy
thank you madam chair
I am thrilled to be in this spacious
room with a good sound system that we've
instituted last term and it's uh it's
great it's a nice way to start as
opposed to two years ago where we were
spread out all over the place and doing
video conferencing so it's nice to nice
to start here start out I wanted to say
that
uh this is my fifth term
uh and uh my fourth uh term here in ways
and means I was the first elected in
2012 from Barrington and I served on
Municipal and County Government
I am now in Greenland so the district is
Greenland and rye
Rockingham 24.
my background is in fundraising I was
the
Chief fundraiser for Iowa public
television for 15 years and the chief
fundraising officer for New Hampshire
public television for 10 years so I was
responsible for raising all the private
money that came into two those two
multi-million dollar organizations
or public television
uh today I am a serving as a on the
Granite State uh why Board of Trustees
former chair of the Seacoast YMCA
advisory committee and a number num a
number of other non-profits and they tap
me to say come on in and help us raise
some more money so that's been my my
background
I'm also I was a selectman in Barrington
in 2012 that era and I still serve on
Trustee of trust funds in Greenland
and that is my
background thank you thank you very much
representative is it Baldwin
fold in thank you sorry got it
thank you
um I'm Bill Bolton Plymouth and I joined
Sally fellows as two parts of
member
um Grafton 8 contingent uh the first
time I got elected to the house
my first and and I'm a former state
employee I I had 30 years
um with both public health and Secretary
of State office
and I became
ultimately the direction of the division
of Vital Records Administration and
saw that budget and the staff as we
moved
archives built
feet be Fruit Street and I was uh
election Ave or something like that or
um
anyway I retired um in 2008 I became an
at-home implementation
software
that um basically had to be installed in
all 50 states and seven jurisdictions to
be able to share Vital Records uh data
in each other also the national centers
for health
I had my own small business time and uh
two years ago I let's pull the plug on
that and in the in the interim I started
working as a board member ran for the
select board in Plymouth and um got
elected as my fourth term
and the deal with Plymouth is um yeah we
deal with
um rather Frugal budget we have a
elementary school a Regional High School
and a university
and just about 60 of our properties are
owned by non-profits
and uh property taxes obviously a great
concern for Plymouth because here we go
up at least
or it might be even more so
I I'm very lucky to be a place on on
this Committee just
follow
X's
and
that's pretty much thank you
this is just an opening introduction
there'll be plenty more time hopefully
to get to know each other on a deeper
level but representative spilsbury
thank you madam chairman
welcome to the ways and means you're
welcome back
uh my name is Terry spilsber you'll see
me on all the lists as Walter but please
address me as Terry my Nick
um I grew up on Long Island and found my
way to Northern New England going to
college in Maine at Bowdoin
um and uh was determined I would
eventually get back here but I
went hither there and yawn in between
I went through law school and uh funny
enough I enjoyed tax policy enough that
I took three courses in tax in my law
school degree uh went on and it later
got a MBA from Columbia
I was Maritime Council in the U.S Senate
for several years
and got heavily into the side of law
that most lawyers don't get into and
that is drafting legislative language
so so tax policy and legislative
language are things that are near and
dear to me
uh this is my second term uh in house
and turning the ways in me
second term
and uh I'll just say that uh
I've been very pleased to be on Ways and
Means because I think it stands out as a
committee that's very collegial
and it's remarkable what a high
percentage of the bills we report out go
onto the consent calendar
um and I find that even in those
situations
uh where there's a divided opinion it's
uh it's a very substantive and
respectful discussion so
um I think that makes it an extremely
satisfying committee to serve on
just sort of a preview for those who are
joining the committee for the first time
it makes it a very enjoyable commit
I agree representative Doucet
hang on good to see some familiar faces
and some new faces
um I'm Fred Doucette I'm serving my
fifth term from the town of Salem very
much looking forward to the Dynamics
might be under the circumstances we all
find one another under with this evenly
divided house and evenly divided media
makeup
um just real brief because I like to
pride myself on brevity and I think uh
chairman almie will remember I I speak
often about having two ears in one mouth
for a reason uh I'm a lifelong public
servant I serve the United States Navy
as a corpsman uh upon my honorable
discharge I served 25 years as a
professional firefighter paramedic in
the town of Salem
and subsequent to that I've been retired
let's see the end of this month it'll be
12 years and like I said I'm in my fifth
term and I pridefully
uh serve the citizens of New Hampshire
and the citizens of my town of Salem and
I very much look forward to getting to
know each and every one of you and
getting some business done for the
people who put us here thank you
representative liply
hi I'm Nicole leapley uh my first year
here conquered I did excited to be on
this committee um I love learning new
and
Talent and I love a challenge so I'm up
for it
um I spent 20 years in higher ed of a
doctorate from the
Dania
literature
so I was
a professor
2018. just recently at St Ansel
I grew up in Nebraska
um came out here for a job at Sani and
my husband is a small business owner I
have two school-aged kids so very
interesting tax policy I'm in my second
term on the Manchester school board so
also in
that perspective
I'm the president of my condo
association
um so also interested from that
perspective
and
I look forward to
assuming lots of information to get up
to speed thank you
representative soti
hi my name is
firm
glad to hear that though
a partisan type committee as I would
education here
I'm glad to hear that Ways and Means is
a more bipartisan
approach
education and that was
experience
uh let's see my background is um I have
a degree in the philosophy and
I work my way instruction I took report
uh worked as a probation officer for
years
and then I decided to make some money
got into real estate now I only manage
my own real estate so I have my own
business I figured that would translate
well over here in uh isn't me
for now anyway
representative Smith
thank you madam chair
um my name is Jeff Smith I represent
Dover uh this is my first term so
definitely also learning go
um Ways and Means are certainly not my
choice but I do think I'm a good fit for
it I actually have a master's degree in
data analytics from Southern New
Hampshire
um so I'm used to looking at numbers I
do forecast modeling for my position for
Staffing uh so predictive modeling
numbers spreadsheets are definitely
where I have a lot of background in
um I'm a father of three I have three
children including a toddler so I am
probably younger than most here and I'm
definitely juggling my time between work
family and looking forward to doing the
work for the people of New Hampshire I
have a background in public service I
actually did a couple years of service
in Americorps one of them actually here
at the Department of Education
sustainability work for after school
programs
um so State work
um public work and certainly numbers are
are thing that I've really appreciate so
I'm looking
I'm working with everybody
thank you
representative lburger
my name is Susan elberger I'm a second
generation American born and raised in
Manhattan didn't own my own home until I
was 36 years old so a somewhat different
experience from many of you I have a
master's in counseling and spent a good
number of years working in addiction
treatment including as the executive
director of a small non-profit where
budgeting was fun but I turned around a
deficit to a profit in my first year
which I was very pleased about
um
I served on the school committee in
Lexington Massachusetts for six years as
part of that I was part of a group that
was trained by the Harvard negotiation
project and principled negotiations
which I really enjoyed and hope to
sort of
work on with myself and potentially with
others while I'm here
I also served in town meeting as an
elected member both in Lexington and
then in Arlington Massachusetts
um
I've been a Contra Dance caller for more
than 40 years if any of you have any
idea what that means I'd be happy to
talk with you about it more and I'm
looking forward to collaborating with
you all
and last but not least I hope I don't
mispronounce your last name
representative orace
oars
thank you madam chair
uh this is my first term I've been in an
accountant auditor
senior analyst controller VP of Finance
really that good with them
uh let's see that was a joke so let's
see I've helped start two businesses my
wife had a photography business and then
I was a consultant or some of my
co-workers said I was an insultant for
Johnson and Johnson Healthcare
a retired I taught high school for five
years
I taught accounting at a community
college for two years my wife Rosemary
and I have four children and four
grandchildren so I'm on the other
and my kids have turned out to be
attorneys and nuclear engineers and that
kind of thing you know as far as the
attorneys go
not sure where we went rock but we're
working on that
uh let's see I know when I die I'm going
to heaven because I've already been in
the army of Fort Evans
uh I was happily retired until Dan
McGuire who lives close to me
grab my ear and talked me into doing
this
and uh
knowing Dan I know of course Carol
McGuire
put me in touch with that gentleman over
there ubery oh no it's already and uh
here I am folks thank you very much
that's wonderful thank you so much
everyone
um
there we go uh so I thought now we could
go over kind of what some of the
procedures are in the committee and some
of the expectations and talk through
some of the scheduling that we have to
worry about
uh we do want to make sure that this is
a very respectful committee
uh and that we are very orderly and fair
in how we do things did every one of you
attend a freshman orientation
did you get a chance to win you did not
so we there will be some procedures that
we might have to pull you aside and just
help you through a little bit but you
remember the pink cards remember that as
part of your training so anyone who
comes to testify on a bill will have to
fill out one of those cards and they
will all be sent to me and we'll try to
be very fair about making sure everyone
gets heard
and a reminder on the public hearings is
that we are here to listen when we have
a public hearing on a bill we first hear
from the sponsors why they're sponsoring
the bill
uh and then we hear from the public and
our job during the public hearing is not
to argue or to debate our job is to
listen so I'm going to be pretty strict
about that
um you will ask all of your check
questions for the testifiers through the
chair
and we want those questions to be actual
clarifying questions and not debate
we're not here to question them they're
on their logic we are here to further
understand why they are supporting this
bill
when it's the executive session so later
on in the process is when you'll have a
time to say your piece
and when you might be prepared to make a
statement does anybody have any
questions about the distinction there
yes
so I just have a question about your
statement that you make questions the
chair because I'm new to that I know
that in Edna you know
asked permission to ask a question but
we didn't have to say what the question
was yes that's exactly the same yes you
just but so we don't have 20 of us
trying to ask questions all at the same
time you just go through the chair and
we'll I'll try to keep notes and he'll
keep me on top of things
um to make sure we we recognize everyone
but I just wanted to make sure that we
don't have a situation where we find
ourselves debating with a presenter
because that's really not our place or
our place in a hearing is to listen to
the public and in our case we might also
be listening from experts from agencies
and so forth
just want to be clear about that any
other questions on that process
there will also be a blue sheet where
people can register basically their
thoughts whether they are for the bill
or against the bill
and for folks that want to testify who
cannot be here there is a portal
that legislative Services has that they
can submit and of course everyone will
have access to our email addresses so
you'll be inundated with emails from
time to time so people educating you on
their views on the bill
okay we yes
forgot about that on are we
oh dear
I'm sorry
that's okay something along
this line
of
um
that's okay but plenty of time to just
discuss this yes representative
self-worth just to double check my
understanding is this term
executive says there's going to be more
planned ahead we had kind of random ones
before that could just happen anytime so
that if they do it it's a big change
we're going to try to be as planful as
predictable as humanly possible
one thing I just want you to be aware of
and I'm sure representative almi is
aware of this sometimes we over schedule
time for hearing and then we find out
that we only needed five minutes and we
have an hour block of time
in a case like that if we've already
mentioned that there might be an
executive session that day we might
think it's a good time to
to exec some bills so we could open up
an executive session it would be more of
a time management thing than anything
but of course I'll consult with a
ranking member on that to see does that
make sense should we try to get that
done today especially on the less
controversial bills he said we'll use it
as a time management tool
representative Army
yes there we'd been
told that we shouldn't do unless we're
sure that everyone already
oh is
we do have a lot of new people
don't have very many bills
got a lot of Revenue
at least until the second committee
built
right well and what's something I wanted
to talk to you a little bit briefly
about according to Ann Fitzgerald I
don't know if you've met her she runs
the committee services department and
she gave me an indication that she
thought we'd have about 22 bills coming
to this committee which is actually
quite low
we share this room with the criminal
justice committee
they think they're going to have 80
bills
so
we are sharing this room with them I've
talked I've talked to the chair and
we've agreed that Ways and Means will
have this room Monday Tuesday Wednesday
they will have it Wednesday Thursday
Friday
obviously using Wednesday as a wiggle
room day
we only have about nine bills in our
possession so there's only so much we
can do right now
and and just so you know the revenue
estimating usually doesn't start until
sometime in February
partly because a lot of the agencies are
very busy working with the governor
right now on his budget so they'll only
they'll have some availability but they
may not be able to give us all the
numbers quite yet however
I would love to start some agency
presentations in any other presentations
I've heard of a couple ideas already
that we can get early on to educate
ourselves so that we're ready
and we might do some Bill hearings early
on just to get them going
um we probably won't have any executive
sessions for quite a while because we
have a lot of other work to do
um and we'll go through that in a little
bit more detail but you know I don't
want to get too far behind so I'll start
scheduling some stuff soon like for next
week
but it's just for planning purposes next
week I do not believe we'll be here
Wednesday Thursday or Friday
that criminal justice will be in this
room we may be here Monday and Tuesday
depending on what we can schedule that
soon
so for planning purposes I hope that
helps someone asked me you know looking
ahead when do I make my doctor's
appointments I think Thursday and Friday
are fairly safe in January
um obviously Thursday is going to be
important for session days but I don't
see us having a session day in January
or at least not to the very end because
none of the bills have exact none of the
hearings have gone through so we don't
have any exact sessions so we have
nothing to go to the house session so
that's for planning persons I think
Thursday Fridays are pretty open
right now
okay
I'm sure yes I know I mentioned uh
during our phone
at uh I'm on the
we do not want you to get kicked off it
we'll try to be reasonable as best we
can but we do have deadlines so I want
to go over that a little bit so thank
you for the cue
um
we are here to do good work but I don't
want to exhaust you
we'll try to get full days in so that
when you come here you know you're here
from let's say nine till four
try to fill in a full day uh obviously
with a lunch break as much as we can
I will work with representative all me
to try to determine how long we think
these hearings might be so we can plan
our time well and so that we're not
super surprised a lot of the bills that
we will hear will not be going to reps
Hall
because most people don't care
um you know we'll be able to stay in
this room for a lot of it we'll be able
to plan a lot of this okay it go ahead
yes
oh representative thank you
one category of bills that uh
requires earlier attention
those that have to go to a second yes
I've always found
it's unclear which bill is our second
committee
so
hey uh do oh
God in the waves we've only got it
um that really UPS the ante you've got
to get get those things
get them or oh maybe you could talk to
them absolutely thank you uh I don't
know of those yet the only indication we
have is what when we see it listed under
ways and means what the deadline is
that's the only indication that we know
because not all bills that have a fiscal
Note require a second committee that I
believe is determined by the speaker's
office and he works in concert with the
house Clerk
and I don't have any advance notice on
that beyond what you see on the general
court website as well right now I
haven't seen any indicated as second
committee bills but absolutely those
will be as soon as we see those we
should schedule those and get those
moving we also are a second committee
for other committees so if something
first goes to criminal justice let's say
marijuana policy it would then
potentially come to us for the tax side
of things so we'll end up with some more
bills that we don't know about yet if
they pass through the first committee
representative Army
thank you
um I've got as of last night or 11.
great and that
Foods one on
moving also sole Proprietors
Tech
and
sponsor
okay great uh well we'll see if we can
what I guess I'm thinking is if we can
schedule some Bill hearings next week
Monday Tuesday
and maybe a pres presentation or two
so we'll mix them up a little bit we get
a little bit of both but I don't want to
get I think it's hard and you'll start
to see this tomorrow when we start to do
back to back presentations for eight
hours straight can be a little bit
overwhelming
so we'll try to break those up going
forward now so for the next two days
these are the economic briefings we do
together with the Senate Ways and Means
Committee to kind of kick off the year
these should be a very kind of high
macro level
in you know high level thinking about
what is happening in our agencies what
they see coming down the pike
um you know
nothing just really to give us an
overall indication of where they think
the economy is going so we'll hear from
the inside experts and then we'll hear
from the outside experts to get us
started and then we're gonna we'll keep
drilling down into more and more detail
and you will have plenty of spreadsheets
to look at
um do not feel like you have to memorize
anything you know really just absorb try
to absorb as much as you can just ask
questions get more and more comfortable
as we do the deeper and deeper dive we
won't actually put pen to paper on the
revenue estimates for probably six weeks
so we've got time
to be learning and thinking and asking
good questions and like I said if
there's something that we're not you're
not getting enough information on and
you want more information on
we'll get a presenter to come in or as I
mentioned Jennifer our researcher can
help us understand the history behind
some things as well
she has really good access to well what
are other states are doing what has been
the impact you know all that kind of
stuff she'll be able to help us with
that so any of those requests send my
way and we'll do the best we can
okay couple little decorum things
um water is totally acceptable on the
table but really nothing else if you
don't mind
um the you know when it comes to using
your phone you obviously turn off the
ringer
um laptops we don't I don't mind if you
have them on the table and I don't mind
if you use them because let's say a
topic comes up and you want to do a
little bit of research you want to read
the bill a little bit or you want to
look at something that's absolutely fine
but what we don't want really in a
public hearing is to have you glued to
your laptop and not listening to the
public right because that would be
disrespectful and we want to make sure
people feel welcome and we appreciate
their time yes one exception hopefully
what's that I've got to type the stuff
off oh yeah yeah oh speaking of which
so uh representative Platt has
volunteered to be our committee clerk
thank you
that is awesome because usually the
chair has to go find someone to do that
it is a lot of work and we really
appreciate that because he's going to be
taking notes for all of us
for the record and we appreciate that he
will also be calling the role when it
comes time to take a vote during
executive session
any questions so far
all right deadlines so now for the
freshmen this is your Bible right here
make sure you have your calendar and
you're looking at it constantly
Jennifer and I will do our best to
communicate with you via emails but
please keep checking these because we
don't want to miss something
the deadlines are right up front page
two
and this is what we're held to
so this is what we always have to be
paying attention to and I appreciate
your reminding me if we get close to
deadline and we haven't done something
uh so very importantly Thursday February
16th is the last day to report house
Bills going to a second committee
so no later than that any of the bills
that are marked as a second committee
Bill have to have been exec from this
committee
I would strongly prefer not to get
backed up a tight against any deadlines
I'd like to have a little wiggle room
so we're gonna that's what we're going
to strive to do as soon as we have the
bills
gonna do the best we can
yes
just ask
Eric
on
I out for
I was already talking
about on one that is in our committee
problem
somebody looks at a municipal property
on Bill and thinks oh that's the text
but actually they take
did not
property
at them
and on but there are also bills that end
up in
about that but
okay I appreciate all of your eagle eyes
if you see anything like that so just
for the freshman's sake
usually if a bill has a an impact on the
budget or it has an impact on taxes or
Revenue there would be two committees
involved one would be the policy
committee the underlying policy and then
the second one would be us if it had to
do with a tax or fee or Revenue impact
make sense so there are certain ones
that will come to us only because we
deal with that policy for example
cigars and cigarettes believe it or not
all comes to us I believe I don't think
it ever goes to Commerce
and we have to deal with that sometimes
if it if it's not to do with the money
um I once ended up with a bill about on
putting the tobacco products that were
attractive to children behind the
counter and it went to Commerce
interesting well so it and the house
clerk really reads through all the bills
and tries to send them to the right
committee and they do a really
exhaustive read to you know look at the
rsas that are being impacted they do the
best job they can but we might have to
give them some feedback along the way if
we see something go awry so yeah
and there is one other there are two
other
objectives in our committee description
one of them is to look out for the
treasury of the state which is very
Broad and the other one is dedicated
funds
which historically ended up here because
I was the one that started doing
dedicated funds
26 years ago I think it is now and on
and that doesn't
make as much sense to people sometimes
as if it's about uh nursing
dedicated fund they think it should go
over to Health and Human Services or
something like that sometimes bills that
make more sense in the financial terms
to come here end up over there because
they are awfully busy when they're
trying to assign these bills as you know
and they they can't know everything
either
yeah thank you for that reminder we'll
go over that in more detail don't worry
about that yet but sometimes we have all
this Revenue coming in we think ah we've
got plenty of money and then we realize
well it's been dedicated to something
else so you'll learn more about that
representative jinnegan did you have
something
oh Ellery thank you representative
ullery
Laurie
oh Madam chair
um
you talked about uh receiving emails and
I just wanted for the benefit of the
freshman
if it's a bill about speeding on Lake
Winnipesaukee you can expect now
four to five thousand emails
uh and I don't think there's any
obligation to save those from out of
state
you can that's what the delete button is
for
just
to the back of your mind other emails
that come to your legislative email
account are open to public records
requests uh if they go to the let dot
ledge email they are saved here
but if you have a private one that goes
through the dot ledge one they may or
may not be so just keep that in the back
of your mind uh as a legislator anything
that does with legislation is open to
public records uh our public records law
so if you have a separate account for
legislative activities maintain that
just so you don't get in trouble with
that on on the ethics side
um just uh something to remember uh you
were talking about dedicated funds uh
and you're going to explain that later
that there are two types of dedicated
funds and fund funds and how they
operate and and that so we'll have a
deeper discussion of that it has
generally if I'm not stepping out of the
line been the policy of this committee
to look a scance at dedicated funds
um that for a variety of reasons some
are very necessary
there's no question about it our
representative almie and former
representative major spent a lot of time
taking a look at various dedicated funds
to
figure out which ones should which one
shouldn't we had several dedicated funds
a couple of which were non-lapsing they
just had this huge amount of money that
was
doing nothing
if we're going to collect the tax the
taxes got to do something
which is something that if I'm not
mistaken not speaking out term it's
something we need to take a look at a
tax does it do anything
and if it does something well then the
policy decision comes up from that
um and you're also going uh I would
suggest that we uh have somebody run
over this for the freshmen so that we
can uh understand
what uh your monthly Revenue focus is
you should be on the email list now if
I'm not mistaken yes you'll be getting a
daily uh Revenue uh statement as to how
much money is coming in but how much
money is coming in does it really mean
anything because it's how much money is
going out when
um if I'm not mistaken and that that
becomes more clear when when you read
this yeah so you were you received this
email over the weekend actually Chris
Shea was very busy uh the state of New
Hampshire monthly Revenue Focus this is
actually produced by the department of
administrative services but incorporates
obviously information from the dra and
other agencies It's a Wonderful read and
there's beautiful graphs usually in
color which really is nice so this is a
real go-to I've been receiving this for
12 years I love it
um and it we will have someone hopefully
go over this in more detail very soon
we'll do a deeper dive on this for you
so you can ask questions okay awesome
representative Almy
yes do I have permission to give a
counter view to this idea that that
attacks may not do something
go ahead
a tax goes into the general fund or the
education trust fund or some other major
fund on a fee
actually those are the only two I think
and a fee
can easily be set up
that on sometimes
goes elsewhere than where it was
supposed to go and I have been fighting
on the dedicated fund committee for
quite a while now since we got our new
comptroller who thinks that that's okay
as long as the legislature wrote it into
the law
all right to be continued on another
date please
representative fellows thank you madam
chair
I just wanted to ask if maybe you could
take it up with a speaker or somebody
that at some point not right away if
there were some training related to
emails in the legislative
um the legislative emails because some
what I've been able to do is I identify
I put I made rules so I identified
certain recipient people who were
sending me an email I those
automatically get forwarded to my home
account and then there are some emails
that I make go to a special folder
because they're from the committee chair
and and there are other things that you
could do but I I just think that it
would be useful for people not right not
this week you know but when they start
to get into it there are a lot of things
that you can do with with that
legislative email account okay
representative ulery
downstairs in legislative researchers
gentlemen are rich
uh Sagan Lambert Rich Lambert I've been
named to skip me uh just go ahead and
ask those questions directly of him he's
on the ethics uh joint religious Lady of
Ethics Committee he's the staff person
for them and he will answer any
questions you have
gladly Rich Lambert downstairs
legislative research it's over in the
executive office building second floor
almost directly
uh it's attached to OLS it's right
beside them you go in the far uh the
northernmost door
the governor's door if you will go to
the first hallway take a right take a
right into the first and you're right
there
to your point representative fellows if
I hear that there's a general need for
more training or more services or more
anything I would certainly speak to the
speaker about that for you
representative
thank you this is probably an elementary
question but just something I if we need
to talk about this offline I'm fine with
that but
um how does the Ways and Means Committee
obviously we're looking at revenue and
the money that's coming into the
treasury and the the what we're
collecting uh that's vital to the budget
writers because they have to know how
much they're working with how do we work
with is there a relationship that we
have with Finance the finance committee
uh do we communicate that with them uh
what is our is there a working
relationship with our committee and
those folks yes and no we have very
separate jobs
uh we provide the revenue estimates and
what we'll do once we we're going to
drill down we're going to take little
minor votes all along the way first
we'll start with some straw votes see
where we're at then we'll get more
specific then we'll get more serious and
then we'll come up with a final final
resolution and we will present a house
resolution hopefully it's bipartisan
unanimous on what we believe our Revenue
estimates are and then that that's what
they will use now saying that
um this is something that will be
evolving I believe especially given the
circumstances that we're under and the
fact that we will have to produce those
numbers before we have very important
data from dra on business tax receipts
in April so we'll have to give it to
them but we might need to revise those
numbers as we know more but that is our
job is to provide that information to
finance and then they decide how to
spend it
good yeah did anyone have something else
over here
questions
yes go ahead
representative Platt yes
um we have some bills in front of us
already to cut this tax or that tax
that's great I like cutting taxes but
without the revenue impact and how it
affects the overall
uh Revenue stream I I I find it hard to
make a decision without putting a bigger
picture around it how do we get that we
will request well first of all we'll
have a fiscal impact statement so we
will hear from dra their best kiss in a
static situation of what that impact
will be and then of course we will hear
you know I know there's some lobbyists
here from some of the industry folks
hopefully they will present to us when a
tax cut bill or tax increase Bill comes
in they will let us know what they think
the impact will be and then we're going
to have to bring our life experiences in
and figure it out and make our best
decision but we're a long way off from
that we'll also invite our researcher
maybe outside organizations to weigh in
give us their thoughts on what it all
means
we'll have to find out yeah thank you
yes
thank you on
take a look for instance at HB 100
fiscal note is on the back
this is very frustrating but this is
what we get these days the first thing
is a chart that says we have no idea
what this is going to do
and then it provides an analysis how
they got to trying to get some idea of
what it might do and then this year for
the first time
on they are giving us on the back of
that first page of the fiscal note on
impact through to FY 28. we never had
anything but the existing and it doesn't
even if I remember if I think it doesn't
even have
on the prior year to take a look at
which makes things a little difficult in
some cases
on but this is really important for us
because we've passed a lot of bills that
say in this year it's going to do this
and that year it's going to do that the
other the third year it's going to kill
attacks altogether
and the third year is outside of the
purview
of the previous fiscal notes
but on
it does it is does take a fair amount of
reading and then there is representative
ulery's unfavorite most point on table
two static analysis
I actually would like to tell reps and
Valerie that
I had a minor concussion in the fall and
I forgot to put in the bill that was
actually going to start us towards a
place where maybe we could do some
non-static analysis
and but uh next year it will be here
so um
but static analysis is all that we can
really expect out of the Department of
Revenue Administration they want to
cleave as closely as possible to facts
what that means though is that they
frequently give us analysis based on two
years prior when the audits are finished
on and then they try to think to
estimate
where we'd ought to be today based on
that one
and then they have to try to just
continue to estimate on that basis
so for the future when you've got
something that might be a recession
coming up or you might already be in a
little sludge of a recession in some
industries that can be important
and so this is
going to be our job to try to
figure out how to interpret those but I
think it would be really helpful
unfortunately the person who needs to do
it was here this morning he can very
does a very good job of taking us
through these as does the commissioner
of Revenue
administer yes thank you representative
all me and uh representative Oliver
you're next but I just want to mention
I've already met with the commissioner
of dra and asked her to come see us
soon and more often than ever before and
her team to help us really drill down on
all of this and she has agreed to do so
so representative ulery yeah the
commissioner has a the commissioner has
a great deal of experience having
basically done it from the ground up
from the staff level to rising to being
in charge of everything so she has a
pretty good grasp of thing I think the
representative from Lebanon regarding
the uh static analysis uh just uh to
clarify the terminology static means
you've got this figure you've got this
figure you subtractor at them together
to come up with something but you the
only figure you know you have is as
representative only said two years old
so you're not doing anything current and
the state has not seen fit to rent
Watson for a couple of days which would
cost more than our budget
uh
but it would be nice if we had access to
Watson to plan that out but uh I'm
looking forward to seeing your bill
because that that's one of the things
that we have to do is guesstimate and
our guesstimation is going to be
difficult in this environment with a
large amount of money floating around
doing something and further if I could
thank you regarding the fees taxes and
fees are two separate things fees do
something taxes or taxes are just
Revenue generators but thank you for
that definition and I don't necessarily
disagree with your point Thank you madam
chair
thank you and back to deadlines uh and
scheduling
I think we'll start a little bit on the
slower side but plan it to ramp up as
we're getting to the later part of
January into February but we're going to
be busy in the house in general
through April 6 would just cross over
okay so keep that in mind
try not to plan any vacations until
after that please we're going to need
you here
um I know that's tough It's a Long Haul
we tend to generate a lot more bills in
the house than the Senate does go figure
so the right after crossover we get a
little reprieve because we have less
Senate bills coming over right so that's
that's when you can kind of plan on a
little bit of a deep breath but it's
going to ramp it's going to get busier
and busier because this is a budget year
so expect it to be busy in March okay
questions on that
awesome
all right what else do I have oh we've
had uh there's a chance that we could
also do field trips
I'll have to spark up my laptop for that
but we had one lobbyist for a company
a request or offer that we could go
visit a company and learn more about the
industry
give me a moment and see if I can find
it
um this had to do I think with tobacco
let me see if I can find it
there was some Warehouse in Kentucky
does that sound familiar
Okay so
now those are you know you don't have to
go you but it will help instruct you
when we start to see bills about that I
personally haven't seen any bills on
that topic yet but there may be some
um apologize let me see if my I can
connect to the internet here
McLean does that sound familiar yes
McLean is a distributor of many items
sold in convenience stores this includes
tobacco and they would like to invite us
to do a tour of their facility
I believe members would benefit from
seeing how tobacco taxes are collected
for the state as well as a first-hand
look at a major distributor involved in
the supply chain supply chain so
kantukook is a suburb basically of
Concord it's only 10 15 minute drive so
it wouldn't be I don't think it'd be too
burdensome for you uh what do you think
what do you guys think interested yes
could be fun
okay
uh
from
yeah
uh if you haven't been involved in that
whole world it is eye-opening and
something I don't know a lot about
um so I'm open to scheduling it and then
you can certainly if you're something
you want to do great if not no big deal
representative plett I think fairly
early on because then we could hit the
ground smoking
[Laughter]
um another thing to mention for
scheduling is sometimes we will have a
hearing and then we won't do anything
about its exact session because it's not
complicated easy
other times especially when it comes to
the revenue stuff
we will do subcommittees
of the committee as a whole so we'll do
the initial public hearing and then
we'll come back and do a subcommittee of
the whole to really work through the
numbers okay so we're a little different
from some other committees which would
break out into like Commerce for example
breaks out into different three
different divisions and they do
subcommittees on just about everything
here we'll do more subcommittees of the
whole unless it's a very minute topic
and we can get three or four people to
just drill down on that issue
okay yes representative
we've done it both ways there we've
definitely done subcommittees in the
sense of a smaller group to focus on
this that or the other thing that
seem to be amenable to
maybe constructive work by a smaller
group and that's worked well then we've
done those Committees of the whole uh so
you know whatever seems to fit uh I just
wanted to mention two other categories
one is uh there's I don't think this has
been mentioned but maybe it has with
we've got the monthly Revenue Focus
we've talked about that there have been
there are two other sources of data of
Revenue data
that I receive and I think most people
on ways of means but from before
receiving I just I just want to be sure
maybe Jen knows that everybody's going
to get this stuff uh one is from the dra
and it starts in the middle of the month
and it's a more detailed source of
information about the revenue from the
business tax for example that there are
estimated taxes
that have come in
and they're at this level
and you can see the last year in the
last year and the last of the previous
month and so forth there are refunds
that have been paid you get a sense of
what's happening on the refunds
you could start start to drill into
what's happening with the business taxes
it's a very good source document and uh
so I just want to be sure maybe you've
set it up or maybe Jen has or maybe it's
automatic I don't know but in past years
it wasn't
so let's make sure that everybody gets
that and then Chris uh
has his own
daily presentation of aggregate revenues
that he starts sending out about the
middle of the month from lbao
and that's just another way of checking
on what's Happening very useful so I I
just want to make sure that that stuff
gets out absolutely I agree I believe I
mentioned that to the dra commissioner
already but I will make sure maybe
Jennifer can help follow up with that
that we want both of those
two regular emails to go to every member
of this committee
do you know what we're talking about
double check yeah it is very very
valuable I agree did you have something
else uh sorry representative Ames why
don't you go ahead and finish well it's
a different different category but uh I
I don't think uh this was mentioned but
I could have been daydreaming
um and that was uh the gambling side of
things we we have a
a policy and revenue responsibility for
all the gambling uh activities that are
allowed in New Hampshire and uh and that
has taken up a lot of time our time in
the past week we're the only committee
that understands these issues so I just
want to mention that and we may be
consumed by it uh here now on the you
know as issues erupt uh in that Arena
they come to us I just wanted to mention
that
representative Ames did you have
something else Dad no
no okay I representative Almy did you
have something to add yeah I just wanted
to say that that uh those documents that
come especially the one from the dra
that comes out every day from the middle
of the month on you can get obsessed by
those numbers
on you may get really upset on Tuesday
that we're way behind and then on
Wednesday they've made up a gap and
we're ahead on but what really matters
is the final day of the month because
that's the one that he's talking about
where you get the refunds you get the
um
the on
tax payments and the estimates the tax
payments are on after you've get sent a
letter and told you didn't pay this tax
or part of this tax
um so on it's the last day of that when
you get these huge charts and they're a
little hard to print out which is a
problem I did get them to
start designing them so that they would
go on a legal piece of paper but if you
make them any smaller then you can't
really see what you've printed out
so on
and then
uh
I don't remember things very well
without writing them down anymore so I
don't remember what the one on the other
one that's okay we got plenty of time
and just don't panic guys I think
there's gonna be a lot of information
coming at you you do not need to
memorize it or anything like that look
for Trends just look for understanding
where things are going how they come in
but don't get too worried food is here
but representative janigan did you have
something
thank you madam chair I just want to add
something very quickly I know when I
first started looking at those daily
revenues and it would say you know maybe
it's the 20th of the month and you'd
look at it and it would say you know
revenues are 20 million below
just realize that when you look at the
next day and more comes in that number
is going to go down and typically what
we've been seeing lately is by the end
of the month we've actually been running
a surplus now that may not continue but
just realize that number is only as of
that particular day so
thank you
this is a great stopping point for lunch
unless anyone had something else to add
and I apologize I can't see all of you
over here on my left anything over here
Dad okay great let's break
um and so lunch will be served in this
room please stay enjoy each other's
company get to know each other and we
will reconvene at 1 30 sharp to hear
from the CPA Society thank you
good do you want to go ahead and get
started welcome
good afternoon
great Madam chairperson members of the
committee thank you so much for having
us here today
thank you can you all hear me well great
my name is Robin Abbott I'm the CEO of
the New Hampshire Society of CPAs and I
would like to thank all of you for
allowing us to come and give a brief
overview of the accounting profession in
our state offered by some of the most
educated and successful practitioners
that are also members of the society as
a brief overview we're a Statewide
non-profit organization that works to
develop and maintain High Professional
Standards and offers a wide array of
legislative technical support and
networking opportunities for its members
advocacy educational Partnerships and
professional development are what we
strive to provide and being here today
aligns perfectly with our goal of
helping to understand the complexities
which this field is very well known for
as you may all know
we are also very proud of our business
Partnerships and collaborations
including that of the New Hampshire
Bankers the New Hampshire bar and most
importantly the Department of Revenue
Administration we have fostered these
relationships and have a wonderful
working relationship with all of them
including quarterly meetings with
commissioner step and her team
today you will hear from four of our
esteemed members Michelle mcveady
Corey Reynolds Kevin Kennedy and Karen
LaSalle who is our board chair at the
society
on your agendas my contact information
as well as Teresa rosenberger's who is
our legislative Advocate and helped us
schedule today's presentation and we are
grateful to her
please feel free after this presentation
to reach out to me directly if there's
any follow-up you need or if you'd like
me to reach out to any of the presenters
today and I will make sure that happens
so again thank you so very much for
having us today and I look forward to
you hearing from what we have to say
so I will welcome Michelle mcveady up at
this time
so we've done our best to um summarize
this for you but it's a lot to
to put on paper so
bring it real close here okay
hi there uh thank you madam chair and
fellow committee members for having us
here today I'm Michelle mcveady I am
co-chair of the tax and legislative
Committee of the New Hampshire Society
of CPAs
I am also a licensed CPA and partner at
Co-op advisors CPA firm in Lancaster New
Hampshire
at Coast advisors we specialize in
accounting and tax services to
New Hampshire and Vermont small
businesses ranging from 500 000 in
Revenue to 5 million in Revenue
so my section today for the presentation
is to provide an overview of the New
Hampshire business profits tax
also referred to as BPT
we'll talk very high level
about what the tax is who's subject to
it and other facets of the BPT
so what is BPT BBT is an apportioned net
income tax on business activity
conducted in New Hampshire at a rate of
7.6 percent for
tax periods ending in 2022
and 7.5 percent for tax periods in 2023
so that's reducing one tenth of a
percent
[Music]
the tax applies to any organized any
Enterprise organized for gain or profit
carrying on a business activity within
the state
except for non-profits who are exempt
from taxation under the Internal Revenue
code
the taxes applied in an entity level for
any business at or above ninety two
thousand dollars in Gross business
income
the filing threshold is a very recent
increase from fifty thousand dollars
which was the filing threshold for 30
years
C and S corporations Partnerships single
member LLCs sole proprietorships
for federal tax purposes are all New
Hampshire taxpayers and are subject to
the BPT tax
I will also note that there is no
requirement
that the activity be a trade or business
that as identified under federal income
tax purposes and therefore may include
residential and Commercial rental real
estate activities
if gross rents
or in other income derived from the
property exceed 92 000 the filing
threshold
so it's usually gross rents or if a
taxpayer sells a property in the
property
um obviously usually would have a gross
proceeds over 92 000 that would make
them subject to New Hampshire business
tax
to calculate the net business income New
Hampshire starts with the federal
taxable income of the entity and then
makes adjustments to that income based
on certain income
in deductions that differ in treatment
from the IRS so pursuant to RSA 77 a
colon 1. New Hampshire has adopted the
Internal Revenue code AS of a particular
date for each taxable year the current
Internal Revenue code version that is in
effect right now is the code as of
December 31st 2018.
the version has not changed since the
New Hampshire statute changed it as of
1-1 2020.
it includes the significant tax cuts and
jobs Act of 2017.
admin adjustments are necessary to
account for the version of the Internal
Revenue code adopted by New Hampshire
the most common adjustments that are
seen are one the amount of Section 179
expense taken on a federal tax return
if it is in excess of the amount Allowed
by New Hampshire and which is as of
today is five hundred thousand dollars
for that's again Section 179 expense
another common adjustment is bonus
depreciation
for assets placed in service during the
year bonus depreciation is allowed
federally under internal revenue codes
8K but is not allowed at all for New
Hampshire BPT purposes
and then the third comment add back is
estate income tax base
taxes
we'll also see other adjustments that
aren't as common but so I'll just go
over those really quickly
adjustments for foreign dividends
consisting of guilty that were not
previously subject to BPT and or foreign
dividends consisting of
deemed one-time repatriate repatriation
under the tcga which is the tax cuts and
jobs act Kevin will speak more about
guilty later in the presentation
other TCA
tcgaa related adjustments are business
interests deducted in excess of the
federal limitation and charitable
deductions in excess of the federal
limitation
and then finally a quite rare adjustment
is the amounts deducted under the
internal revenue codes section 181 which
is a treatment of certain qualified film
and television and live theoretical
Productions
so changes in the federal income tax
like what we've seen during the pandemic
often brought State Conformity through
legislature for example the PPP loan
forgiveness that was received by most
small businesses
was not taxable by federal statute
resulting from the cares act because New
Hampshire does not have a rolling
Conformity with the Internal Revenue
code
special legislation was required to make
PPP loan forgiveness non-taxable to New
Hampshire businesses
another significant adjustment that is
quite unique to New Hampshire is
relevant for Partnerships single member
LLCs and sole Proprietors only
and that is the reasonable compensation
deduction
[Music]
um
so these businesses can deduct
reasonable conversation for personal
services performed by a proprietor
partner or member
for the business organization a
proprietor partner a single
member LLC whose owner performs services
for the business may take a reasonable
compensation deduction
on the businesses BPT returned return
return for the for those services
there is a safe harbor of seventy five
thousand dollars in the New Hampshire
statute where the business does not have
to demonstrate whether the deduction is
reasonable
to the extent a compensation deduction
exceeds a safe harbor reasonableness is
often demonstrated through using
Internal Revenue codes section 162 and
from there using a number of
authoritative documents related to
section 162 to justify the
reasonableness
of the deduction section 162 addresses
deductible expenses for businesses for
federal purposes to the extent that
expenses are ordinary and necessary for
the business organization
[Music]
if a business was not able to take a
reasonable compensation deduction a
prior year due to insufficient business
profits the business May adjust this
year's compensation deduction to reflect
the under compensation
in the prior years
the amount of the deduction however
cannot be reduced below zero
you might ask why the reasonable
compensation deduction isn't applicable
to C or S corporations and this is
because the owners of these entities are
or are likely to be paid through a W-2
wages
for the services that they have provided
and therefore is already deducted from
the gross business income Partners
members and Proprietors do not receive
traditional W-2 wages and therefore the
business expenses do not reflect
salaries and wages paid to the owners
[Music]
um
next I'd like to talk about net
operating loss deductions also referred
to as nols
in brief net operating losses each year
are collected and used against future
business profits a business can carry
forward an nol for a period of 10 years
and a maximum of 10 million dollars
this increase from one million dollars
in 2013.
for tax periods ending on or after
December 31st 2022 which is the filing
season we are heading into the deduction
for nol is limited to the less lesser of
nol available or 80 percent of the
current year taxable income for BPT
so for an example if a business was it
has an nol available for prior years
totaling a hundred thousand dollars
and the current taxable year current
year taxable income is a hundred
thousand dollars the nol available to
apply is eighty thousand dollars so
eighty percent of the current year
income this leaves twenty thousand
dollars remaining of taxable income and
twenty thousand dollars remaining of an
nol carry forward to be used against a
future tax year
um to close out I'll just make a brief
mention of credits New Hampshire has
several credits that can be used to
offset BPT
the most common among businesses is the
BET credit or some say often call it bet
credit
the BET credit is generated through
business Enterprise tax paid in the
current year in the prior 10 years as it
has a 10-year carry forward
this leaves a perfect segue into the
next section of our presentation as we
have Corey Reynolds come up um he's
already here so talk to you about the
business Enterprise tax
thank you excuse me just one moment
a ton of information
fortunately as a business owner I have
to deal with all these personally can we
pause to see if people have questions
absolutely
anyone over here have any questions yes
thank you madam chair um I had a
question on could you just explain what
bonus depreciation is sure so bonus
depreciation is a federal
um so under 168k allows a business to
basically deduct the entire cost of a
asset that's placed in service during
the year so if a business owner bought a
tractor tractor cost seventy five
thousand dollars under regular
depreciation they would depreciate that
tractor typically over a five or seven
year period
bonus depreciation allows them to allow
to take it all in one year the Year of
service and so New Hampshire says Nope
and they so you would have in that case
practitioners would carry you can still
take it for federal purposes but New
Hampshire would then deduct it over the
five or seven year period depending on
the life of the asset thank you you're
welcome
anything else yes representative Albany
thank you on many years ago now we had
to deal with the Safe Harbor and the
compensation deduction and at that time
there were some major abuses going on I
would like to know if the small
businesses now feel that the the law is
fair and the way it is being applied is
fair
um speaking from my own experience it um
I do think that it had a positive impact
on practitioners and business owners
being able to substantiate a
compensation reduction at 75 000 or
below
um I don't know if anybody any of my
peers behind me would like to comment
but I yes I think that it has a general
positive effect on that
in the interest of time I think we want
to we do want to ask some questions but
we don't get too far on the weeds today
we can hopefully always ask you to come
back absolutely okay great is that okay
if we do you have a quick question
quick one okay go ahead like any
profession you have your acronyms what's
tcja yes tcja is stands for the tax cuts
and jobs Act of 2017 that the Trump
Administration passed
thank you please proceed
all right thank you Michelle
so
my name is Corey Reynolds I'm here from
Baker Newman noise I'm a senior manager
there our firm works from a really mid
to large size businesses goes from a
mid-sized developers you know up to
multinational
operations that do business all over the
world my personal Focus tends to be in
the world of real estate development and
investment
today I'm here to talk to you about the
business Enterprise tax which Michelle
did mention it really is a tax that runs
parallel to the business profits tax in
many ways so the business Enterprise
acts commonly referred to as bet or bet
is a 0.55 percent tax on the total
dividends compensation and interest
expense that's paid by an entity and
we'll go into each of those factors just
to provide you a little bit of
information and one key takeaway there
is it is a tax based on these amounts
paid by The Entity it's not a tax on
that income from operations
for 2022 a business is subject to the
business Enterprise tax if they have
gross business receipts of at least 250
thousand dollars or they have that an
Enterprise Value base of 250 000 that
Enterprise Value base being the
combination of dividends compensation
and interests for 2023 that 250 000
threshold is going up to 281 thousand
dollars
uh starting through the factors so first
talking about dividends so Dividends are
not just what you would consider you
know stock dividends from publicly
traded corporations but it's cash
distributions from any entity of current
or accumulated New Hampshire profits
um I think it's easiest to describe that
just by providing a brief example of
what that would look like so it's you
know say year one of operations for
business they have a hundred thousand
dollars of net business profits and no
cash is removed from the business they
don't pay anything out to the the
members
then coming into year two they have 50
another fifty thousand dollars of New
Hampshire profit so at this point the
accumulated New Hampshire profits is a
hundred fifty thousand hundred year one
fifty year two and say at the end of
year two they distribute 125 000 to the
members well at this point you're
accumulated earnings is 150. you took
out 125. so that whole 125 was
accumulated or current earnings so that
125 is considered dividends for the
purposes of the business Enterprise tax
then at that point you have 25 000 left
of accumulated earnings so going into
year three what does it look like if we
then make a distribution in excess of
that amount so say year three it's break
even and we make forty thousand dollars
in distributions well 25 000 of that is
dividends for business Enterprise sex to
the extent of our accumulated earnings
that are left and the remaining 15 would
not be subject to the business
Enterprise tax perhaps it's a return of
capital or debt Finance return uh
distribution something along those lines
moving on to the next Factor
compensation so compensation's a little
more straightforward and it will be your
W-2 type compensation that you pay to
your employees directors officers who
whoever it might be
um and then there's a few additions to
there over that you know regular W-2
income subject withholding so those
common additions would first be the
employer contributions to retirement
plans so that's also subject to the
business Enterprise tax and the
compensation factor and then also as
Michelle mentioned the compensation
deduction if any compensation deduction
is taken on the New Hampshire return
that's also considered compensation for
the sake of business Enterprise tax
moving on to the third and final Factor
here so interest expense so interest
expense is exactly what you would expect
there's nothing too creative here it's
going to be your interest expense on
mortgages loans V equipment loans
shareholder loans whatever might be just
normal interest expense paid in accrued
during the year is that's part of that
factor
so if someone's subject to the tax you
go through all three of those factors
add them up apply the 0.55 rate and then
you get your business Enterprise tax
liability for the year and Kevin will
touch a little bit on some of the
considerations on a multi-state entity
and how that would change the
apportionment of how much of your
business Enterprise tax base is subject
to tax within the state
and going hand in hand which and we'll
we'll get back to how the business
Enterprise tax ties in with business
profit Stacks I'm going to take a quick
run down through a lot of the credits
that are available both with the
Enterprise tax and with the profits tax
and so first one on the list r d tax
credit research and development and go a
little bit more into depth on this one
just because it it tends to get a few
more questions in a lot of ways it
mirrors the federal tax credit for
research and development where you're
looking at a credit related to the
expenses paid for improving business
processes developing products patent
software types of items like that often
companies will hire a third party to
come in and take a look at their
operations to determine how much of our
operations are actually related to R D
type activities
for New Hampshire purposes they just
focus on the wages so that any wages
related to R D and there's an
application process so after determining
how much in wages related to R D during
the year that they're going to claim for
their Federal application well then they
make an application to New Hampshire
that says well here's the amount of
wages we had related to R D and the
amount of credit we're applying for the
amount of credit of being 10 percent of
those wages so if you had fifty thousand
dollars of r d wages you're putting in
an application to New Hampshire for five
thousand dollars of credit
what New Hampshire does after you this
application is filed is they only have a
set pool of money that they're giving
out for the r d credit so I believe the
number someone else can correct me if
I'm wrong is about seven million dollars
is about the total pool of credit that's
available so based on the amount of
applications they get how much credit is
applied for each per each entity who
applied for an r d credit will then get
a proportional piece of what's available
if there's more than seven million
dollars of credit that would that were
applied for
one you know once after that's been
determined they receive a letter from
the New Hampshire dra just letting know
here's how much credit you have you can
you can claim this credit on your tax
return and attach this letter saying how
much credit that we issued to you
go looking at some of the other credits
we're going to move through a lot of
these ones pretty quick so the koas
County Credit which is just related to
creating new jobs within koas County
there's the erz credit which is a credit
for Capital Investments and employee
hiring in specific parts of the state
cdfa credits hey
Community Development I can't I also
Finance Authority Finance Authority
thank you which is a 75 percent credit
for contributions to certain economic
projects within the State education tax
credit this is also a credit based on
contributions to certain programs within
the state specifically for a qualified
scholarship organizations insurance
premium tax credit I don't think too
many of us here deal with that very
often it's just related to certain uh
taxes paid by the insurance industry
and then just last one I'll mention real
quickly the CTE centers tax credit
Career and Technical Education Centers
this is similar to cdfa or the education
credit I credit to businesses for
contributions to those Career and
Technical centers that's used for
salaries of apprentices
so and then moving on to our our last
credit here so looking at the business
Enterprise tax credit
that can be used against the business
profit stack so tying really these two
parallel tax systems together
so each year once after that business
Enterprise taxes determined any amount
of business Enterprise tax that's
incurred during a year can be used as a
credit against any business profits tax
that was incurred during the year
if you don't use all of your business
Enterprise tax credit that's created in
a year that unused amount can carry
forward up to 10 years to continue to
offset business profits tax in future
years
again I think it's easiest illustrated
by just talking putting a few quick
numbers on it and putting making an
example so let's say in year one a
taxpayer incurs fifty thousand dollars
of the Enterprise tax and forty thousand
dollars of the profit sex
well they have
they they've created fifty thousand
dollars of business Enterprise tax
credit because of that fifty thousand of
Enterprise tax so since they only have
40 000 of business profits tax
their Porsche their business profits tax
is reduced to zero and then there's ten
thousand dollars of Enterprise tax left
though Enterprise tax credit left over
so they'll have ten thousand dollars of
credit carry forward for up to ten years
at the end of that year really their tax
liability what their the cash that
they're actually going to pay to the
state is the fifty thousand dollar bet
liability just that just the business
Enterprise tax liability that they
incurred
and just an example of what it looks
like for the carry forward so then year
two okay we occur 50 000 in business
Enterprise tax again but it's more
profitable year so we had ninety
thousand dollars in the profits tax
so our net business profit sacks after
we apply our Enterprise credits is gonna
be thirty thousand dollars as we have
the ninety thousand dollars of profits
tax we have the fifty thousand dollars
in current year bet credits from the BET
pay this year and the ten thousand
dollars of credit that we carried
forward from the prior year
then our bet and our Enterprise tax is
still fifty thousand dollars
so overall your tax liability what
you're actually paying in cash to the
state is that fifty thousand dollars of
Enterprise Tax Plus your thirty thousand
dollars of net business profit Stacks a
total of eighty thousand
and that's all all for me right now
unless we have any quick questions I'll
I'll pass it on to Kevin
representative orrs
thank you madam chair uh Mike the one
thing you mentioned about r d is that
the businesses only take salary
percentage
that's r d related or is there more to
it as and if this building was an r d
Center could they write this off or a
percentage of it so for New Hampshire
purposes all you can claim is the wages
and when you look at the federal level
there's a lot there's many more expenses
that can become that can be claimed but
New Hampshire just focuses on New
Hampshire wages related to the r d that
was including the federal application
okay thank you thank you madam chair we
will drill down on all of these a little
bit more especially with the dra so any
other quick questions clarification yes
representative
thank you madam chair just a quick
question on the the carry forward the
way you described it makes complete
sense my question is who's who's
tracking it are you depending on the for
example a business has a 10-year carry
forward in year one and year two that
might be more carried forward year three
it's reduced in year four at some point
how do you know where the 10 years ended
for each is it up to the business to
track that or are you guys tracking that
it's a combination of it's a with within
the tax forms that are filed with the
New Hampshire dra each year it does
report how many CR how how much credit
is left that was earned in each of the
prior years so each year that carry
forward schedule is provided to the
state
okay great thank you
thank you very much
good afternoon
I'm going to start my timer so I don't
go long because I tend to be a little
long-winded and I get all jazzed up
about this stuff so
my name is Kevin Kennedy I'm a
CPA I have been for about 30 years in
this great state of New Hampshire I'm
one of the managing Partners at my firm
Maloney and Kennedy I'm also a New
Hampshire Society of CPA's board member
and the other co-chair of its tax and
legislative committee currently I'm also
a member of the legislative committee on
potential worldwide reporting for New
Hampshire a a bill which was introduced
by representative Schoenberg so so far
they've discussed New Hampshire taxation
of businesses this part of the
presentation is to comment on topics
including what needs to be considered
when an entity is conducting business in
more than one state and if it has a
multiple State filing requirement how do
you allocate the profit of that entity
among the states that they have to file
in beyond that we'll talk about what
considerations might be needed when you
have separate businesses that are
commonly owned or have some sort of
common control and whether or not they
need to file some sort of combined tax
return together and lastly I will touch
base on some items with regards to
foreign entities that have a connection
to New Hampshire taxpayers
so in this realm of multi-state Taxation
the first term I'd like to bring forth
is Nexus now Nexus roughly defined is
the requisite contact between a taxpayer
and a state before the state has
jurisdiction to tax the taxpayer meaning
when does a taxpayer have sufficient
presence within a state to make them
subject to that states taxing rules and
regulations now generally if a entity
has a physical presence in a state you
have Nexus physical presence being you
have employees there you have property
there maybe you go into the state or or
you lease property there
however many states expand the
definition of nexus Beyond physical
presence including New Hampshire to
something that looks roughly like if
you're doing enough business in our
state then you've got a form of Nexus
here this is often referred to as
economic Nexus which is different than
physical Nexus
so the one hurdle that states have
relative to economic Nexus is what's
known as a public law 86 272 and this
law says it prohibits a state from
imposing a net income tax on a seller's
business if the taxpayer activity is
limited in that state to just the
solicitation of orders so if a business
is an out-of-state business and all
they're doing is is soliciting orders in
a state this law says you don't have
Nexus in the state this state can impose
its income taxation on that particular
business
now in recent history this public law
has undergone various challenges to its
interpretation many of you might have
heard this back in 2008 there was the
South Dakota versus Wayfair decision and
the Supreme Court essentially said
instead of physical Nexus for sales tax
not income tax sales tax purposes we're
actually going to use an economic Nexus
policy meaning that if an out-of-state
entity vendor is shipping stuff to a
state and they have enough presence
economic presence not necessarily
physical presence within a state that
state has the right to require this
entity to collect and remit sales tax
over the state and I know currently and
in the past there has been some
legislation here relative to this
particular issue and the ability for
out-of-state
agencies to tax in state and I'm not
going to get into that right now but I'm
just letting you know where where Public
Law comes into play here also this
public law 86 2 72 has been interpreted
to apply only to the sale of tangible
goods real stuff hard stuff not
necessarily the sales of services and
intangible goods so given all this
relative to Nexus that's the the first
layer that a business has to consider do
they have a Nexus in a state and if the
answer is yes we do then likely they
have a filing requirement within that
state once they've determined that the
next step is my next term in this Arena
which is called apportionment which has
been used already
and apportionment generally refers to
the formula used by a state to determine
what percentage of the business's net
income is allocable to it and is taxable
how do you apportion the pie among the
states to determine what's what's
taxable now previously New Hampshire and
Most states applied a three-factor
apportionment thing that you looked at
property they looked at sales they
looked at compensation and the
percentages of these numbers within a
state to the total were used to in a
formula to determine the bottom line
apportionment or percentage that was
taxed in a particular state
many States including New Hampshire
recently have moved to looking at just
sales for this apportionment
consideration as a matter of fact this
single sales effect in New Hampshire
started this year in 2022 and you're
probably wondering and probably we don't
know the answer yet what's the effect on
Revenue by moving to single sales and
the answer is well it just ended like
two weeks ago we don't really know what
that is yet and I I would be very
curious to see if Department of Revenue
actually has enough information at this
point to provide that and of course
nothing simple in the world of Taxation
and there's lots of complications
relative to apportionment for instance
what's denotes a sale and where did it
occur
so many states New Hampshire included
have laws and regulations defining how
to interpret this where where did the
sale occur where should that sale be
apportioned now for tangible property
often a sale would be considered in the
state where the product was delivered or
potentially it would be where the title
of the property exchanged hands every
state has their own rules New Hampshire
addresses this by saying regardless of
the conditions of the sale we don't care
what the the terms of the sales are fob
shipping point or whatever wherever the
product is delivered if it's delivered
in New Hampshire it's apportioned to
this state now the only hurdle that New
Hampshire might have with this is again
that public law and Nexus issue which is
if it's determined that state doesn't
that entity doesn't have Nexus in New
Hampshire New Hampshire may not be able
to tax the delivery the delivery of
those goods in this state
relative to the sale now that's tangible
property relative to the sales of
services
historically Most states applied what
was known as cost of performance and
cost of performance said wherever the
work was done to to provide that service
that's the sale that's where the sale
was apportioned but recently two years
ago New Hampshire moved to what's known
as market-based sourcing and
market-based sourcing which many many
states have are now applying means
whoever whatever state received the
benefit wherever the customer was for
that service wherever that state is that
they reside that's where you apportion
the sale so I'll give you a quick
example graphic design person in New
Hampshire gets hired by a Massachusetts
company and they're going to pay him ten
thousand dollars to come up with a logo
they do it and they ship it down to
Massachusetts
that was a service creating that logo
now under the New Hampshire market-based
sourcing rules and Massachusetts has
this rule as well they both say that's
that's a Massachusetts sale because does
the benefit for that service happened in
Massachusetts and these are new and very
very complex I'm just hitting a very
high level
so now we've addressed the issues of
Nexus we've addressed the issues of
apportionment the next issue is what if
you have a lot of companies that have
some sort of common ownership or common
control some states require you to
combine these companies together when
you report because they don't want you
setting up different companies and
shipping income off to other states they
want a Level Playing Field so this is
referred to as a unitary filing and
right now New Hampshire has unitary
filing and they require companies that
meet the definitions of having companies
that have enough common ownership or
control to include all those entities on
the return and apply the apportionment
across all the entities but the entities
are only up to the United States borders
and it's referred to as Water's Edge
once you hit the water
you're no longer going to include any
other companies in this unitary filing
so it has to be a U.S company to be
included in the unitary filing the
committee that I'm currently on is
looking at the other side of things
which would be worldwide reporting so
you've got foreign entities that maybe
have a relationship or ownership of from
within the U.S or New Hampshire company
owns it or individuals do and they
potentially you would include the income
from those entities on the New Hampshire
return When You're reporting if we move
to worldwide reporting
uh and that's what partly what this
committee is is investigating and
researching is what what are the pros
and cons of moving to that
um the uh the last item I will comment
on
um relative to foreign entities is the
tax cut and jobs act which was mentioned
before created a new level of foreign
taxation it used to be that foreign
taxes uh the only time foreign income
became taxable in the US is when the
money was repatriated it came back from
the foreign country into the U.S the
guilty tax which stands for Global
intangible low tax income was attacked
by the tax cutting jobs act that said
you know what if the conditions meet
certain criteria that foreign income has
to be reported on the federal return and
you get certain deductions and you get
certain credits but you still report it
on the federal return the last budget
time the New Hampshire budget was done
it was put into place that New Hampshire
would take half of that guilty income
and include it on the business profits
tax return so New Hampshire is get is
saying to some degree a level of foreign
income being included on the business
profits tax return now we're still
investigating how that is going to
affect if we move to a worldwide
reporting module instead of Water's Edge
but it's all part of the factors
considered as we move through and my 10
minutes are up I know it was an awful
lot to take on I spoke very very quickly
because I didn't want to miss anything
because I get really jazzed about this
stuff did I say that already and thank
you for your time
that was excellent thank you any quick
questions
no let's keep going thank you
I just wanted to say he's guilty
you were right
did you have so go ahead
inside unders as as I remember on we
started market-based sourcing in 21.
and we don't really know what it's done
yet but it looks okay
oh you I'm not aware of the results yet
I think we might have put feelers out to
the Department of Revenue but I'm not
sure they have enough information
compiled yet either
foreign
thank you go ahead
all right thank you nice job Kevin
all right Madam chair and esteemed
Representatives my name is Karen LaSalle
I am a partner with plodzik and
Sanderson here in Concord New Hampshire
and we now have an office in Manchester
and as Robin noted I'm the chair
currently of the New Hampshire Society
of CPAs and we are so happy to be here
today with you and it's so great to see
such a robust Committee in in so many
new members today so it's really great
to be able to give this update on the
new taxes they have put me at the end
here just in case people were sleeping
we wanted to wake you up with some a
little bit easier taxes if that says
anything about my intelligence versus
Kevin but I'm going to be covering the
interest in dividends tax so probably
one that you've heard of a little bit
easier of attacks I will say
um on on a number of levels the the last
one I'll cover at the very end so
interest in dividends tax is for really
any Resident of New Hampshire who or
it's been a resident for the year or
part of a taxable period it's for gross
interest in dividends from all sources
that exceed two thousand four hundred
dollars for individual filers single
filers or four thousand eight hundred
dollars for married individuals filing a
joint tax return during a taxable period
for Partnerships LLCs and associations
The Entity has to have non-transferable
shares to be subject to the interest in
dividends tax again the gross interest
in dividend income is two thousand four
hundred dollars during the taxable
period and that has really been the
threshold for quite a long time the
usual place of business is in New
Hampshire for these entities and any
partner trustee member or owner is an
inhabitant or Regis resident of New
Hampshire
for Estates the estate of a deceased
person who was a resident of New
Hampshire for any part of the taxable
period in the gross interest or dividend
again exceeds the twenty four hundred
dollars
so when looking at what is taxable we
actually the Department of Revenue has
come up with these really great kind of
cheat sheets what is taxable what is not
taxable and if you're ever interested in
looking you know you can look up
interest in dividends
checklist they have them for the
business Enterprise tax as well which is
really great they I'm not sure if we
have one for a business profits tax but
it's a really great checklist of what is
and what is not taxable so I won't bore
you kind of with the details of
everything that's taxable and not
taxable but your typical interest that's
taxable your bank interest credit unions
your bonds municipal bonds except for
those bonds that are from New Hampshire
um interest that's not taxable New
Hampshire State and New Hampshire
municipal bonds individual retirement
plans Keo plans New Hampshire Housing
Authority bonds those are all not
taxable
dividends again your typical Bank
dividends corporate dividends items that
aren't taxable dividends that come from
capital gains returns from Capital
liquidating dividends sailor exchanges
from transferable shares again I'm just
hitting on some of the key
um major ones that I tend to see you
know so I don't want to bore you with
the whole list again it's a long list
um so so know that there's there's quite
a few areas that fall into taxable and
non-taxable
the exemption there's the exemption that
I talked about which is also the filing
threshold of the two thousand four
hundred dollars but there's also a
couple other exemptions in New Hampshire
so a one thousand two hundred dollar
exemption available for residents aged
65 years of age or older
a one thousand two hundred dollar
exemption for residents who are blind
regardless of their age
and then there's a one thousand two
hundred dollar exemption for disabled
individuals who have not yet reached
their 65th birthday
the due date of the return is this um
same it follows the 1040 due date so
it's the fourth month the 15th day of
the fourth month so typically what we
think of as April 15th uh depending on
when that day Falls
so I think one of the major things
though that you need to know about the
interest in dividends tax right now the
tax is currently five percent but it is
set to be repealed so for
2022 the tax is 5 for 2023 it is four
percent and it's going to go down each
year so
2024 it's 3 25 it's 2 26 it's one and
then as of 2 1 1 2027 the tax has been
repealed so the IND tax is going away I
do not know myself I don't know Kevin or
if we've heard
um in our talks with the dra with the
the fiscal impact of that is I don't
know that
um personally but but I do know that
that tax has been set to be repealed in
2027.
any questions
so this brings us to the the part of oh
you do have a question representative
fellows okay yeah I just wanted to know
I see that most of you have been reading
something can are those available to us
to read or
we did not prepare formal handouts I
think I do you mind I don't we did not
prepare formal handouts
maybe we could ask them to come back
when we're dealing with actual
legislation or Revenue estimates to come
back and maybe hand out some stuff then
because right now we're doing the quick
again we're going to start high level
we're going to have people come back
we're going to drill down
you know so we'll start high level but
maybe next time you could have something
you could share with us because we're
taking copious notes but there's a lot
to cover here so representative Almy
thank you one thing one thing we have to
remember about them is the closer that
we get to March and then April the list
we're going to see of them
and I I I was wondering
on I never really thought of the
interest in dividends taxes anything
except interest in dividends until
fairly recently when the dra started to
throw in our faces that there is
something called distributions yes which
is quite large part of the tax and how
how does distributions fit into your
description of what you were telling us
about
so the the distributions it depends on
the type of entity and distributions on
entities that have non-transferable
shares
depending on the type of entity are
taxable as interest and dividends tax in
the state of New Hampshire
and
s corporations for instance they're
taxable no matter what and correct me if
I'm wrong Kevin because I'm saying this
off the top of my head s corporations
they are taxable regardless
entities that are like llc's limited
liability corporations limited liability
companies
who elect to be taxed as as corporations
who have non-transferable shares are not
taxed as interest in dividends so
there's some nuances so it depends on
the original entity structure and how
it's set up and then ultimately on how
it's taxed
we do have a question
yes representative good
so you're not talking about rmds you're
talking about
shared distributions
distributions yeah well the word
distribution is in there just trying to
clarify
so our rmds have to do with required
minimum distributions which are
distributions from retirement plans
these are not the kind of distributions
we're talking to within companies
distributions from a company often are
either dividend distributions or draws
like a sole proprietorship who may take
a distribution from his company or
partnership that may take a distribution
from their company and that wouldn't
necessarily be labeled a dividend
because they are simply taking the
income out of the company that
potentially they've already been taxed
on but under the rules and regs and the
definitions certain entities
particularly llc's when if the entity
has a non-transferable share a
non-transferable means you can't easily
sell the interest in the company those
distributions under the current ranks
and rules for a limited liability
company are not considered dividends for
the interest in dividends tax but if
it's not an LLC and it's a C Corp or an
S corp and there is a distribute
solution it's likely to be labeled a
dividend distribution subject to the
personal interest and dividends tax I
hope that clarified it
thank you very very helpful quick
question you mentioned that the
threshold for filing IND taxes hasn't
changed in a while do you know when how
long it's been the 24-48 I think it was
1200 for the longest time I've been here
probably the longest I think I remember
when it was 1200 and I think it's been a
decade or more since since it's been
changed I think it's been 2 400 it's
2400 per person The Joint return is 4
800 but I think it's been over a decade
since I've seen it change and maybe two
thank you very much
representative Almy mentioned that
you'll be getting busier and busier with
your practices so I appreciate that uh
so if you have the bandwidth to put your
notes into sort of an outline of things
that you wouldn't mind sharing with
committee members that would be helpful
because we don't want to disturb you
when you're trying to earn your living
but uh that I think we all learned so
much today and we appreciate your being
here and would love to have those notes
handy when we go back to those topics I
don't Envision I'll have to do some
spell checking but
other than that I'm happy to compile uh
my notes I imagine our my parents we
would appreciate it provide them too
thank you coordinate through Robert
Abbott to get them to great
thank you can anything else committee
members
anything else Robin okay this is
wonderful we just Dove right in I love
it thank you so much
all right folks that wraps up our day
thank you for coming and we look forward
to seeing you tomorrow at 9 00 a.m We
will be in the finance committee rooms
210 lob 210 to 11. see you there